all right Nancy's with us in Chicago and
answer your question for Rachel and I hi
Dave hi Rachel
Nancy hi we I should say we my husband
and I have our 24 year old son living at
home
he is only working part-time and he is
one class away from his four-year degree
and we know we've enabled him but at
this point we just want him to move
forward is he in class he is not okay
after the December graduation date that
he didn't make he said he was sick of
school and he blamed the teacher he is
planning on taking it this fall however
we don't make him cent you don't make
him sound very appealing oh okay no bill
that we feel that he's taking advantages
yeah he's unmotivated he's sitting on
his butt he's being contrary and titled
and everything else that's right yeah
exactly right um right well Rachel deals
with a lot of folks in this Jenner in
that generation that that she's
interacting with I deal with them
because I've got them as children at
that age my son is 22 not facing those
kinds of things with him but I'm not
even close but Rachel I mean what's your
input almost from a peer to peer how
would you expect us to if Daniel did
that what would happen in our place well
through the perspective of the Ramsey
family mom and dad really didn't give us
an option to move back home period for a
transitional period between college
graduation and you know moving and
getting that first job and there was a
little leeway for you know to two to
three months we could there had been an
extreme emergency and you usually yeah
yeah absolutely but it was an
expectation
basically that we would never move back
home and we kind of had to be out on our
own once we left the nest it was up to
us to survive and so so what I would say
probably peer-to-peer more to him as I
would just want him in this whole
generation to be able to be
self-supporting adults and I think
that's just good for him overall and I
think part of that is working and then
getting out you know at 8 o'clock in the
morning coming back at 5 p.m. after a
long day's work you just feel like
you've accomplished something I think
that gives him confidence I think that's
just good for him overall and so I would
encourage you to force him to work I
know you said he's working part-time but
to go get another job or even two more
jobs and just start this flow because
it's so easy I think for so many people
you know when you sit at home and
there's not much going on it's so easy
to be unmotivated and I think that ball
can roll so fast down the hill and so I
would have a goal for him to say hey by
this date you're moving out and so
whatever you have to do between now and
then you need to get it done or you need
to have X amount of money saved and then
you need to move out but kind of just
have a plan for him I think kind of
wandering through life where there is no
expectations or or deadlines or
guidelines I think he is going to fall
into that because I think you guys have
allowed that so and even that we have
allowed it yeah we have allowed it he
doesn't have any dignity well yeah he
doesn't feel good about himself he
doesn't and so I would sit down with him
and you and your husband together need
to be in agreement on this and just say
you know what we love you you have no
dignity that like this you know you're
on track to do nothing and so here's our
situation we are going to love you well
you have to move out and here's the date
that we expect you to move out and you
can put it out there a little ways it
can be two three four five months
whatever I don't care but you need to be
aiming at that and in order for you to
stay here during that time here's what
you're going to do you're going to get
two more jobs
you're not staying out all night
partying you are going to get up in the
morning and do something exercise or
something you are going to register and
get the class finished and and if you do
all of that you can live
here for free for this two month three
month five month thing whatever it is
that's but that's how you pay rent to
get to stay here if you're unwilling to
do all of that pack your stuff now
because this is us loving you well you
are not going to sit here in this state
we're not going to do it anymore and we
love you too much to allow you to become
a spineless jellyfish that's worthless
and we're not going to do it we love you
we think you've got incredible potential
and so you're going to get three jobs
you are going to save money you're going
to avoid debt you're going to attend
church you're going to exercise and
you're going to take this class and if
you do all those things you can stay
here for X number of time at the end of
that time whether you do them or not you
need to move out but by the time that's
over you'll be ready to move out because
you'll have money and you'll have the
dignity of living on your own and making
your own decisions but you can't stay
here past that it's not doing you any
good we love you we'd love for you to
stay but it's not good for you and so
we're not gonna let you okay that's kind
of how I would go at it and I think you
know that first conversation I mean I've
done 25 almost 26 I'm around his age and
so that's gonna be I mean there would be
some growing pains with this that's
going to be a hard conversation for him
to possibly grasp a hard conversation as
a mom I would think so I think you know
the first few months that may be
difficult but I think in two years he's
going to look up at 26 years old with a
job a college degree living out on his
own and he's going to be so thankful
that you guys did this well we have had
that talk with him but we haven't been
firm and you haven't given it set
deadlines
no we haven't so it won't be any put on
the refrigerator don't put the move out
door move out date and read on the
refrigerator door yeah that's the next
thing that we need to do and we've been
talking about it so this is absolutely
perfect yeah and it's not being mean I'm
not suggesting you're being mean I'm
just suggesting you you're loving him
well because Eagles aren't Eagles until
they fly and they can't fly in the nest
turkey sit in the nest
Eagles fly and that you want to raise
equals that's what we're trying to
and that's love mama Eagles and they
wouldn't love their their child let it
sit in the nest until it takes over the
whole thing they push them out of the
nest they literally push them out of the
nest in the wild make them fly and
that's not mean it's so that you can
spread your wings and be what God
created you to be and you're not that
and sitting in your mama's Den watching
Oprah reruns for goodness sakes you know
Rachel we talked a lot about this idea
of teaching to grow money smart kids
part of that is to teach humility and
gratitude and help them grow in those
areas and sometimes the antidote for
entitlement is gratitude isn't it yeah
that's exactly right I think parents
their fears that they're raising
entitled kids and I think you know if
you have a heart of gratitude and you
are a grateful person overall
it's hard to be entitled because you're
just grateful with for where with where
you're at in your situation everything
you have I mean a grateful heart doesn't
have room for an entitled heart and so
out of that though as well I think
gratitude you have to be humble and you
have to have humility and you can't you
know when you're humble you're not
expecting everything you're thinking of
others yeah tied up in entitlement is a
sense of arrogance that's the opposite
of the humility there I'm entitled to
this I'm do this and there's always an
arrogance that goes with that because I
breathe because I walk the earth and
have graced you with my presence you
know that's entitlement crap and so hey
that the opposite that's the opposite of
humility and so teach your kids to say
thank you and freaking mean it this is
the Dave Ramsey show
you
you